bonjour virginie joron
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être en direct
ce matin avec nous sur rt france alors
on attend georges kuzmanovic qui devrait
pas tarder on va commencer avec vous sur
pour parler de cette difficulté de se
présenter à une élection présidentielle
pour les petits partis mais aussi pour
les parties comme comme des grands
partis comme le rassemblement elle
nationale on va on va écouter ce qu'on a
dit marine le pen
tout d'abord des difficultés de de
financer justement cette campagne ce
sera la première question regarder
les possibilités de financement des
campagnes électorales se sont
singulièrement réduites ainsi les
candidats ne peuvent même plus faire
appel auprès des citoyens pour financer
leur campagne présidentielle
la contrepartie était la création d'une
banque de la démocratie mais les
restrictions sont toujours en vigueur
mais avant de parler des difficultés
pour les petits partis le plus gros
problème pour un parti c'est c'est ce
problème de financement comme le soulève
marine le pen
en effet ça fait partie effectivement
des premières difficultés parce que
comme vous le savez une campagne
présidentielle ça prouve quand même
beaucoup d'argent comme l'a souligné
marine le pen effectivement on a sa
difficulté obtenir des fonds puisque
voilà c'est à peu près je crois 22
millions d'euros pour un président pour
une campagne présidentielle et nous faut
des fonds effectivement vous souhaitant
que les banques nous soutiennent parce
que marine le pen fait partie de ceux du
système électoral il faut à tout le
moins que l'on puisse la voir ce soutien
des banques et effectivement ça refait
un peu jour surtout quand ils voient que
c'est le et rennes qui vient de taper à
la porte donc voilà dont nous nous avons
aussi des soutiens financiers mais ce
n'est pas acceptable et c'est surtout
pas suffisant donc effectivement c'est
un regret que marine le pen formule
effectivement puisqu'il avait été dit
par monsieur macron que le système dans
une banque pour la démocratie doit être
mise en place dès effectivement ce point
là a été remis dans les tiroirs à c'est
aussi un moyen comment dire de comment
dire contrer cette certaine opposition
qui pourrait ennuyer ennuyer d'autres
partis à candidater comment comment se
traduirait cette banque de la démocratie
défendu par marine le pen ce serait des
banques choisies qui auraient obligation
d'accorder ces prêts bien sûr tout à
fait décent et sans sans qu'il y ait à
chaque fois cette notion
du bien ou du mal parce qu'effectivement
nous on est à chaque fois mis de côté
vous même on a déjà vu certains de nos
candidats ou des banques ont été
clôturés parce qu'il représentait le
rassemblement national je pense que si
on défend la démocratie on ne doit pas
comment dire contraindre à fermer départ
parce que soi-disant notre mouvement
serait serait pour des raisons
subjectives d'un banquier opposé assez
assez assez conviction et ça ce n'est
pas acceptable il ne faut pas en
fonction du la tendance et de la ligne
politique fermer ou ouvrir certaines
portes florian philippot le président
des patriotes et figures politiques des
antilles pas sanitaire a officiellement
lancé sa candidature et sa campagne ce
week-end il veut peser dans la campagne
comme étant le candidat des antilles
passe comme en autriche d'ailleurs où ce
parti a fait une percée aux dernières
élections mais voilà selon lui il y à un
hic regardé
bfmtv se plaint qu'on ne parle pas de
fond dans cette campagne présidentielle
mais quand on les invite pour un
lancement de campagne ils n'ont même pas
la politesse de répondre double discours
évidemment il adore le buzz débile alors
ça pose évidemment la question aussi de
deux pour ces petits candidats de la
place qu'on leur accorde dans les médias
on a entendu les gens dire que
finalement ils ne savent pas qu'ils se
présentent véritablement pour cette
élection présidentielle or ce n'est pas
le cas du rassemblement national mais
qu'en pensez vous
écoutez c'est vrai que nous sommes
encore qu'au début de ces élections
c'est les candidatures sont en train de
se mettre en place donc effectivement
c'est peut-être pas c'est officiel donc
du coup ça n'intéresse pas les médias
mais après j'ai envie de retourner la
question aux médias effectivement on
sait très bien qu'il ya le buzz qui
fonctionne qu il ya de l'audience aussi
qui permet une certaine comment dire de
faire avancer aussi à une plus ou moins
une chaîne de télévision donc tout ça
fait partie d'un marché comme le sondage
voit bien que les multitudes sondages
effectivement avec à chaque fois les
candidats plus déclaré que d'autres mais
ça fait partie aussi d'un marché
économique donc ça c'est une certaine
analyse après pour fluence philippot bon
ben voilà il annonce sa candidature
il a effectivement vu que certains
résultats aux dernières élections
régionales après effectivement c'est une
question je vous retourne parce que en
tant que média s'est tu parlerais plus
pour les médias mainstream qui qui
effectivement eux jouent plus sur
l'audience et du coup peut-être moins un
intérêt moins à y aller ou pas assez
assez assez conférence à s' est à suivre
après leur meeting mais ça ça
effectivement c'est un marché économique
assez fermé et qui qui produit après
effectivement tout ce que l'on voit des
sondages tous les jours un certain buzz
et à chaque fois la la le cercle très
fermé des invitations cercle très fermé
qui est basé d'ailleurs sur les sondages
c'est ce que vous dites est ce que c'est
normal que la place des candidats dans
les médias ce soit soumise aux sondages
le journal ouest france lui trouve que
c'est pas normal regarder
ouest france ne participera pas à la
grande manif ne réalisera aucun sondage
politique avant la présidentielle et
évitera de perdre du temps à commenter
ceux des autres nous nous consacrerons
reportage à l'anc est au plus près de
celles et ceux qui ont des choses à dire
et c'est ce que disent aussi on l'a vu
dans le micro trottoir tout à l'heure
les gens trouvent qu'il ya trop de
sondage et finalement les questions
principales ne sont pas abordés qu'en
dites vous
je partage en plus cette analyse parce
qu'on sait très bien que le sondage est
un moyen
aussi une manipulation et quand on voit
qu'il ya tous les jours voire deux à
trois sondages sur le sur le même sujet
qu'aujourd'hui c'est devenu la boussole
de certains médias alors nous on est
très prudent sur ces sondages on l'a vu
la dernière fois aux élections
régionales thierry mariani aurait dû
être président de la région paca donc
d'un côté nous
politiques ont les regards donc aussi
moi on va passer on va pas se mentir
mais en même temps c'est pas notre
boussole après c'est vrai que pour les
citoyens ça peut effectivement biaisé
leur choix et entendre à chaque fois les
mêmes noms voilà effectivement ça écarte
de facto les petits candidats donc
effectivement mais les sondages font
partie un petit peu voilà deux de ne pas
dire de là information mais pour est
comment dire arriver à ceux à ce constat
d'effectivement d'une manipulation des
des citoyens parce qu'effectivement
reviennent à chaque fois c'est non
effectivement je partage cette analyse
de deux des citoyens qu'il faut être
prudent et qui effectivement est on le
voit bien même dans les questions c'est
toujours les mêmes questions ni ailleurs
et ça et du coup ça ne va pas de
questions ouvertes en fait dans leurs
sondages ce principe est poussé à ce pas
à son paroxysme puisque on entend
beaucoup eric zemmour évidemment dans
tous les médias en ce moment et
finalement le rassemblement national et
marine le pen ont au moins la voix qui
porte est-ce que c'est dû aussi à ce
phénomène selon moi je crois pas un je
crois qu'effectivement d'un côté il ya
effectivement ce nouveau t1 gens que
personne n'a vu venir dans les effectifs
dans tout le monde il porte un intérêt
et je le conçois mais cela n'empêche pas
que nous nous continuons notre campagne
et que nous sommes aussi hot aussi
visibles sur le terrain mais aussi on le
voit quand même repris par les médias
donc l'un n'empêche pas l'autre
non il ya cette curiosité un que tout le
monde a effectivement ne s'interroge et
donc c'est aussi pour cela que tous les
jours il vient dans le débat mais en
parallèle il ya aussi cette fin je ne
vois pas - en tout cas de communication
sur nos mouvements eric zemmour qui a
décidé de lancer son propre parti on l'a
appris dans le journal du dimanche hier
est-ce qu'il faut un parti derrière soi
pour poser dans une élection
je pense un parce qu'après les
législatives
si après il prétend vraiment être
président à la public il faudra quand
même qu'il est n'a semblé et des députés
donc vaut mieux pour lui qu'il est un
parti au sinon
ça voudrait dire que keane est juste là
pour un tour de piste qui s'arrêterait
pour lui au premier tour ou ou second
tour
quoi qu'il arrive c'est le cas
d'emmanuel macro qui avait lancé la
république en marche qui a eu un rôle at
elle dit il avait déjà assisté il avait
déjà tissé un réseau sur tout le
territoire il avait déjà des foires se
vivent un peu partout et d'ailleurs là
on l'a vu sur le terrain il y avait des
députés dans tout dans toutes les
circonscriptions donc il avait déjà il
avait déjà mis en place
c'était d'ailleurs grâce à son mandat
son sens sa fonction dans le
gouvernement qu'il avait réussi à mettre
tout ça en place donc tout était déjà
prêt ce n'était pas une surprise donné
qu'il a été élu et il a trouvé des
députés qui sont même si effectivement
dans les faits beaucoup de personnalités
nées était inconnu en politique mais ils
avaient les ressources étaient déjà
mises en place je suis désolé pour
georges kiejman au beach qui lui est
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
malheureusement on n'arrive pas à le
vent de ce matin on va parler des
difficultés également pour obtenir les
500 parrainages nécessaires pour se
présenter des maires qui sont déjà
extrêmement sollicités mais depuis
qu'ils sont publiques ces parrainages et
bien les maires se montre beaucoup plus
prudent et ne veulent prendre aucun
risque à l'instar du maire d'aix
surviennent regarder
alors je dit en substance un
malheureusement ce midi j'ai reçu des
propositions farfelues et moins
farfelues sur notre liste on est des
personnes d'horizons différents et si je
parraine ce sera considéré comme un
positionnement ce problème des
parrainages rendu public ça ça ça
empiète également sur la visibilité de
certains candidats tout à fait c'est
vrai que le fait que ça soit public ça
empêche certains effectivement a donné
sa signature parce que comme il l'a dit
ce mr effectivement prendre donner une
signature c'est pas dire prendre
position pour l'un ou l'autre c'est
qu'effectivement par respect pour la
démocratie certains maires préfèrent
bien à sa cause et sa signature donc
effectivement ça aussi c'est un c'est
une problématique pour candidater je
l'entends aussi pour les petits
candidats qui elle aimerait aussi
impulser une nouvelle ligne une nouvelle
politique qui voudrait aussi de
présenter reprises pour que pour
représenter notre citoyen donc c'est
vrai que c'est une difficulté que nous
rencontrons aussi parce que comme comme
les banques soit c'est parce qu'ils ont
des lignes à tenir soit c'est parce que
la publicité va en fait de les
contraindre à s'expliquer auprès de
leurs concitoyens et aussi dire ou pas
qui sont qui sont pas parties prenantes
donc donc ça aussi ça fait partie des
difficultés de cette élection est ce que
ça favorise la démocratie selon vous est
ce qu'il ya des pressions d'ailleurs des
partis à certains maires pour ne pas
donner un parrainage à un candidat
exactement moi je les ai vus lors des
précédents présidentielle où
effectivement la mère de sa signature
parce que pour lui c'était vraiment un
problème de démocratie parce que à
chaque fois c'est le même problème dans
les dernières lignes droites il nous
rend quelques signatures mais
effectivement marine le pen et notre
parti a je dois être aux présidentielles
enfin je veux dire quand on a vu les
dernières élections quand on voit toutes
les élections nous avons un électorat il
faut qu'ils soient représentés et c'est
vrai que ce maire avait subi des
pressions puisqu'il commune c'est publié
à la fin de
2 cd de la candidature pour cette
élection effectivement il a eu aussi
d'une multitude de coups de téléphone
que ce soit par ses concitoyens que
aussi d'autres mères qui lui qu'ils
l'ont qu'ils ont mis la pression et
après c'est ça va jusqu'à 40 euros
petits ratés subventions etc etc
devraient donc c'est du chantage bon bah
oui mais ça c'est c'est une vérité qu'on
a vu sur le terrain alors idem pour les
candidats des grands partis comme comme
le vôtre par exemple chez les
républicains on entend beaucoup parler
de xavier bertrand ou de valérie
pécresse pas beaucoup d'aidé des trois
autres ain instar de d'eric ciotti qui
finalement lui fait ça sa campagne sur
les réseaux sociaux regardez
je suis le seul candidat de la clarté au
congrès a l'air je suis le seul candidat
à ne pas avoir voté emmanuel macron en
2017 avec mon ami laurent wauquiez nous
avons eu ce courage voilà pour ce qu'il
est ce qu'il dit son dernier tweet sur
la campagne là aussi
après ça procède du sondage pourquoi
certains candidats
ne font pas beaucoup parler d'eux selon
vous en ce qui concerne ndlr notamment
pourquoi mettre en avant xavier bertrand
valérie pécresse
mais là aussi c'est une stratégie qui
concerne leur parti ils ont
effectivement des élections qui sont
encore assez loin donc c'est une
bataille entre eux donc là c'est une
stratégie qui est pourquoi leur parti
sacha les boutiques aussi où c'est un
choix deux parties selon vous est ce que
ces deux ça doit être les deux à mon
avis hein mais effectivement c'est ce
c'est encore une fois le problème je
crois à la con à avec avec les médias
c'est c'était sondage d'un côté qui
pousse effectivement certains médias à
saintes et plus que d'autres sur le
résultat de ce sondage qui fait qu'après
il ya cette dynamique et comme je les
dis c'est un peu le cercle fermé et
vicieux de 2,2 delà de la forme de
l'information en fait donc donc on est
un peu dans dans ce schéma qui est
biaisé et qui peut-être il faut être
prudent parce que on l'a vu aux
dernières élections il ya eu beaucoup
d'absentéisme et il faudrait pas qu'on
revienne à ce taux d'absentéisme qui
était gigantesque
au mois d'avril donc il faut là aussi
que les sondeurs et que les médias
soient prudents parce que moi ce qui
m'inquiète c'est ce qui est ce qui a été
pour nous et aussi pour d'autres partis
un vrai problème et c'est crucial on est
en démocratie qu'il y autant
d'absentéisme à des élections c'est pour
moi un vrai problème de démocratie des
cantons dans ce dans ce schéma dernière
question virginie joron la question du
csa et des temps de parole évidemment
imposées aux médias audiovisuels et
c'est pas le cas de la presse écrite
d'ailleurs ça aussi ça favorise
évidemment ça ne favorise pas
l'émergence de petits candidats
ben oui ça fait partie effectivement
d'un microcosme qui fait que c'est à
chaque fois la même chose effectivement
csa impose un certain temps de parole
les médias comme on sait très bien sont
quand même piloté ils sont en majorité
il peine de sanctions c'est vrai que la
règle
la règle est stricte pour l'audiovisuel
mais après effectivement la presse
écrite quand on voit toutes ces tribunes
qui qui émerge sur certains quotidiens
s'assoit et surtout des quotidiens qui
sont quand même qu'ils ont une politique
très souvent très à gauche donc
effectivement là ça permet effectivement
de mettre plus en avant certains
candidats que d'autres et ça peut être
un problème à terme parce
qu'effectivement là aussi c'est biaisé
et encore une fois ça peut ça peu
comment dire
introduiront impulser une certaine
certaines lignes fin sous une certaine
de certains certaines
îles des puces ou d'autres pour les
citoyens et en tout cas les empêcher
d'accéder à certaines informations
merci beaucoup virginie joron
malheureusement on n'a pas pu débattre
ce matin avec georges kuzmanovic ce sera
pour une prochaine fois merci à tous cas
de votre éclairage et de votre regard de
femme politique justement sur la
question de cette candidature
compliqué parfois donc pour certains
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
merci